hey youtubers is Charlie so I'm going to
be talking about Wally West and Young
Justice season 3 so this is going to
contain season 2 spoilers the show's
been off the air for a while but just
spoiler warning in case you haven't seen
the end of Young Justice season 2
I think it just might be working it's
definitely slowing but not stopping even
at our top speed I'm not certain the two
of us can generate enough kinetic energy
then how about the three of us I may not
be as fast as YouTube but I can add my
fair share of kinetic energy besides I
can't lift a nuke in take all the credit
for saving the world good man Oh crash
yeah come on roll man you can do better
than that
look it's working
the shiny
he'll disable Isaac yes but there is the
problem mine areas the Kid Flash is in
danger
his slower speed is making him an exit
valve for the chrysalis energy in 16
seconds he will cease cease cease what
Bart we have to slow down more try to
siphon off some of the energy attacking
Wally
yeah it's no good Barry
oh man Artemis is so gonna kill me for
this and don't even get me started on
mom and dad kid just tell them okay
you look good really as I feel like a
fraud
well don't you're honoring Wally's
memory by becoming Kid Flash I know he'd
be proud Thanks
so couple core concepts here Wally West
on the Young Justice TV show
obviously as he says in this clip is not
as fast as the other versions of the
flash I think the idea like Jay Garrick
wasn't there to help them out like they
needed more kinetic energy so it would
have made sense to have Jay Garrick if
he's another version of the flash but I
think that that would have prevented
Wally from dying and they wanted to have
like a big death in the episode so that
you feel the weight of everything so
that you know big twist season 3 had it
originally happened as planned they
would have brought him back and it
would've been like oh my god you're not
dead this is so amazing so they tend to
do that but the problem is is the show
was cancelled before they had a chance
to do that so you were left to wonder
what happened to him there's nobody and
you know the rule of comics unless you
see the body he's not dead so here's
where we get to flash rebirth stuff
comic book stuff they've done it on the
flash live-action TV show with Grant
Gustin before - during season 2 of that
show they killed off a bunch of versions
of the flash because of Speed Force
problems so the thing is is that the
creator of Young Justice said that Wally
did not have the Speed Force but the
thing is is that I think he was just
saying that in service of the big twist
that surprised there really is Speed
Force in Wally just got sucked into it
so he's going to have a rebirth in
season 3 but a lot of that depends on
the art that they choose to go with if
they choose to pick up with the Darkseid
war that they were teasing you know with
that Vandal Savage tag in the other clip
that I posted I'll post a link to that
at the end of this so you guys can
re-watch it so if they want to just pick
up immediately with the stuff that they
had teased at the end of season 2 and I
think they will want to do that the
least want to resolve that even if they
don't roll heavy on it is that they'll
tease that they'll start to get their
asses handed to them and then the flash
rebirth Wally West will be one of the
things that helps them finally defeat
Darkseid so Wally gets to sacrifice
himself in a very heroic way during
season 2 and be one of the big heroes of
season 3 but the thing is is that Bart
Allen has already become kid flash he's
wearing a costume that looks exactly
like Wally's he's picked up the mantle
so if you haven't read the Silver Age
post crisis on Infinite Earths storyline
wally west became the main version of
the flash after Barry Allen did
something exactly like young justice
Wally WestEd he sacrificed himself to
save the universe and he seemingly died
but that's just because they wanted to
transition to a new flash in the comics
so you know big comic book twist many
years down the road Geoff Johns comes
onto the flash title starts writing and
writes a story called flash rebirth
where Barry Allen comes back from the
Speed Force so the simplest explanation
is often the best when you're trying to
figure out what's going on with young
justice wally west he probably got
sucked into the Speed Force he will come
back in a rebirth type moment in fact
they just did that in the new flash
rebirth like the DC rebirth title where
Silver Age Wally West from before the
new 52 manifests from the Speed Force
and now they have to Wally West's in the
comics so that gets a little more
complicated because there are two
versions of Wally West in the comics so
don't worry about that for young justice
they're still just going to be one Wally
West on Young Justice but when he comes
back what are they gonna call him well
they'll probably just call him Wally
West and they'll continue to let Bart
Allen become kid flash but you do have
to have that moment where you
acknowledge it where Bart is like do I
go back to being impulse you know I'm
happy to take my old costume you know
here's your costume like most versions
of the flash are fairly selfless when
pushed so Bart would probably be happy
to step aside if wallet came back but I
don't think they would do that I think
Wally would be happy to see what Bart
Allen had been doing while he was away
you don't have her many episodes that is
or however big the time jump is but time
jump that's an important thing too I
think they have to show that it's been
business as usual for at least a little
while maybe a couple years since the end
of season two so you can say they've had
all kinds of funny adventures in like a
quick montage just to kind of catch
everybody up help new audience members
catch up with the characters learn what
their powers their personalities are
like if they've never seen it before and
then they can roll out Darkseid and say
he's been planning this big big attack
for a long time so let me know in the
comments how do you think that they'll
bring Wally West back on the TV
show it just feels like the most
satisfying way to do it would be like it
is in the comics where he just manifests
out of the speedforce
and everyone's like oh my god this is so
amazing so big win of the week Young
Justice season 3 confirmed probably not
going to see a teaser or any concept art
for a little while but here's the thing
we know about the big Darkseid attack
what other storylines do you want them
to do especially if they're going to be
doing more than 13 episodes because
there's all kinds of comic-book stuff
that's happened since the show went off
the air that they could introduce the
flash TV show has had a lot of fun
picking and choosing things from all
over the flash comics from the Wally
West era from the Barry Allen era so
Young Justice could do that same thing
too and let me know in the comments what
other kind of bonus videos do you guys
want me to do for Young Justice be sure
to subscribe to get everything
of course I'll do episode videos
whenever it gets here but until it gets
here we can do bonus videos talking
about plot lines talking about season
one and two and the other big thing that
happened today in the live-action
universe you know over like over at Fox
Studios with the x-men stuff is that
supposedly Bryan Singer is leaving the
x-men franchise he was kind of like the
leader for their franchise so he kind of
directed where a lot of the story went
the ideas they had so Fox is supposedly
eyeing a reboot for all of their x-men
titles that would include Deadpool the
x-men movies The Wolverine movies this
is huge so that's going to be my next
video I'll post that before I post my
arrow episode video later tonight so
there'll be three videos tonight
hopefully I could stay on track but
that's what's coming next
so get hype I just feel like a complete
x-men reboot would be totally fine as
long as the thing that they replace this
stuff with is amazing audiences can be
very forgiving if the new thing you give
them is totally awesome so that video
will post in a couple hours well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for that other young justice
footage and you can click here for a
teaser for killer frost and vibe comic
book costumes on the flash TV show thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you